this is a difficult one for me to share
this is my survival story so if you've
ever felt alone nervous scared if you've
ever felt like [ __ ] well then this films
for you
[Music]
oh no no please be sure that feeling you
feel right now
times it by a thousand and you still
know India what it feels like to walk
around with anxiety every day I'm okay
how cool of that stance is irrelevant to
this narrative what is relevant are your
feelings right now this isn't a symphony
video this is about an even larger issue
than Mead falling off the chain story
building a cold life in
[Music]
so this encouraged me to write something
this world isn't easy
but at least I have anxiety a diagnosed
reason that makes it okay to be crazy
fully daily by my catastrophic
reflection no doesn't hurt when you
continually planning for rejection you
are exposed but you don't expose
yourself meaningless engagements to
gather dust on some digital shelf I have
no reason to hide behind some glass wall
lit by a thousand pixels my fee extends
further than the need to be heard
through the sacrifice of more brain size
this world could be a dark place but at
least I'm anxious I'm constantly
searching for reasons to add color to
life's rayless canvas out of sight out
of mind doesn't exist for me my visions
are vivid enough for a law to become a
believable reality isn't that brilliant
a mental condition that seen a so
negatively resilient see anxiety
depression BPD OCD ADHD all the DS could
be looked at differently for the
sufferers that is you just need to see
that your difference is empathy being so
connected to my emotions is scary as
[ __ ] but I wear them like scars on my
skin so that I'll never be considered a
counterfeit if you like me I see you I
feel you transparent as glass be brave
stand tall and know that the bad times
will pass
you're unique you are remarkable harness
that [ __ ] and you'll truly become
and stop me that's it
I walk the world very differently to
most but closely to a small group of
amazing people this film is for those
people the problem is is most of these
amazing people are too afraid to speak
out to be heard making amends with your
mental health like I've done could be
like having a superpower so if you want
to start talking about mental health
not just anxiety and depression use the
hashtag I'm with you across all social
media platforms or just comment below
and let's start a conversation a
meaningful one I wanted to get
everything about myself out on the table
before beginning this new Jay this was
episode 1 of season 1 and I'll be
uploading every Wednesday at 8 a.m.
Eastern Time my deal with you is that I
will always leave you with something
this channel is about conscious content
so if you like my movies only if you
like them please subscribe to my channel
the link will be on the top line of the
description and it'll also be in an
annotation at the end somewhere yeah
the founder what was that but you're
somebody like yeah I'm fighting to it
yeah so I mean like you can click this
thing yeah
[Music]
cool